salut si vous suivez la chaîne depuis
depuis le départ depuis 2016 vous avez
vu un tricheur revenir sur cette chaîne
qui s'appelle maurice duda les réinviter
à venir parce qu'il nous a pas tout dit
sur la triche
vous allez voir ça après l'incroyable un
tac tac donc dame rouge ici d'accord ici
c'est noir est ici c'est noir donc tu as
suivi c'est facile ou et la dame rouge
ici vous allez voir ça aussi pour le
début je t'aide le joker est pas dessus
et pas de sous donc il est et à un
moment donné même qui fera ça pour les
as rouge tueur frotte un peu et du coup
tu récupères les deux escrocs
vous avez le droit à des bruits de
perceuses régulièrement parce qu'il ya
des travaux dans le bâtiment et qu'on
n'a pas le choix parce que maurice il
n'habite pas à paris et de quand il est
là bas on tourne on en profite
voilà donc c'est des bruits de perceuses
c'est pas des bruits de gens on est en
train de scier
non on fait pas ça c'est parti avec moi
[Musique]
et donc tout à l'heure en off tu me
disais que le but des tricheurs c'était
pas forcément de voir la plus grosse
main parce que sinon ils pouvaient faire
gauler c'est ça c'est trop suspicieux
c'est trop flagrant quand on fait le but
du tricheur du mécanique cela qu'ils
manipulent mais en fait ils stack son
appel stack et stérile classe la main
qui va faire gagner son partenaire y la
classe et coupes
il donne le jeu et l'autre distribuer
c'est lui qui récupère et meilleur
double internet 2 voilà au minimum la
passion que ça c'est pas une bonne main
on n'est pas sur un bon flop je peux te
faire un truc si tu veux avec sa base il
avait donc ok tu vois tout et tout est
complètement normal on va dire c'est bon
je prends juste les cartes tu vois je
l'aimé comme ça donc je peux je peux
vraiment rien faire je peux pas je peux
rien manipuler et pourtant tu vois si on
fait juste un petit classement deux
attaques
et ben voilà bizarrement épanouie qui
regarde la carte flush royale ça voilà
ça s'est passé
non rien à va vraiment tu te trompes tu
déconnes et peut-être des petites
techniques des trucs d'entraînement
tricheurs des choses comme ça qu'ils
faisaient
je sais pas jouer avec les alouettes
jouer avec les as ça c'est ton jeu
s'attend à un vous fait avoir quand même
ça c'est le jeu de maïs duda parce que
monsieur restent en jeu de cartes c'est
des vrais bicycle finition r ction yes
avec à ses côtés les deux cas la tête de
maurice directement dessus
dire qu'on peut on peut jouer avec toi
[Musique]
par exemple j'ai les as qui sont ici tu
vois dans le milieu du jeu d'accord on
va démarrer de la bon on va les perdre
dans le milieu du jeu si tu vois un gars
qui commence à apprendre le jeu de
cartes comme ça tu vois et puis halal
passer à un peu à le manipuler toute
voix qui localise un peu les à skis
coupe etc ou qui recoupe d'accord pour
dialoguer il en train de manipuler quoi
mais là il se dit tiens à je vais couper
sur un an ces ballons alors par contre
comme par magie tu vois tu peux tu
manques ya pas d'assistanat si si par
contre si tu frottes un peu peut
récupérer un premier essai grâce au
tatouage battu frotte sur le 2ème tact
et un deuxième à ça c'est sympa
donc du coup on a on a les à cela on a
les seins se bouge
alors pour les as marre tu frottes un
peu et du coup tu récupères par un
premier instant un deuxième à smart que
tu peux examiné très important pour les
as rouge tueur frotte un peu et du coup
tu récupères les deux à ce projet
j'étais très pratique si ce qui est très
pratique aussi voilà bah ouais ça et là
tu te retrouves avec un carré d'as on va
essayer on va mettre les rouges ensemble
et noir ensemble j'ai vraiment que
quatre cartes
tiens j'ai demandé tu mets ta main comme
ça premier à se voir juste ici notamment
tu ne bouges surtout pas suivi du
deuxième à soit très important tu me
laisses combien de temps pour échanger
les as rouges contre les as marre une
seconde c'est fait c'est fait c'est
rapide du conflit c'est ça le but c'est
c'est le but c'est de ne pas se faire
prendre quoi est-ce que tu as aussi
ensemble des tricheurs et on va dire les
mecs qui étaient dans la rue
et qui arnaquer les gens à ce que
c'était une forme de tricherie c'est le
joueur de bonneteau les trios zaabal au
bonneteau c'est typiquement un truc de
tricheurs mals typiquement un truc de
tricheurs je peux trop montrer le
bonneteau le vous leur montrez peut-être
mal et vous l'expliquer quoi donc là le
but du jeu ça va être de miser sur wii
la dame rouge où est la dame rouge
exactement alors du coup la dame rouge
et real commence au milieu et à ses
jours au milieu
ok donc tac donc on va refaire on va
bien tu l'aies les cartes comme ça voilà
donc on a la dame rouge donc c'est
simple d'accord tac tac tac tac
elle est j'ai pas suivi à cause du bruit
je crois qu'elle est on est au milieu
aurait bien vu tout à fait vrai tout à
fait on va passer à la vitesse
supérieure après donc regarde tak tak
donc dame rouge ici d'accord ici c'est
noir est ici c'est noir donc tu as suivi
c'est facile ou et la dame rouge ici
1000 euros hélas est perdu et là c'est
perdre et là c'est perdu maintenant
parce que c'est toujours au milieu
d'accord lui en fait c'est un jeu où on
gagne jamais l'idée c'est quand je
montre la dame noire la dame rouge
pardon je jette la carte dont la dinde
rouge effectivement est ici là j'ai pas
tricher mais quand je vais trichet en
fait je vais jeter la carte du dessus si
vous passez au ralenti vous allez voir
que je jette la carte du dessus je pose
une carte noire donc la dame elle est là
donc ici on croit que c'est la dame mais
dont certains carte noire et là je
montre deux fois la noire je refais la
même parce ce qui fait que j'ai un temps
d'avancé la tac tac tac tac je mélange
forcément non mais c'est génial
et puis après j'imagine bien mais je te
demanderai pas de le dévoiler mais
j'imagine bien que six tentes et qui met
aussi sur la dame rouge il ya des
techniques quand même pour les soldes
chez toi toi tu verras ça tout à l'heure
mais tu as un benneteau à toi ou
personnelles il faut le faire ok ok + 1
bonneteau sur du divertissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc là comme on est deux on va dire je
suis ton apprentis mais l'idée c'est de
voir ouais quand comment sur une table
on pourrait afficher ensemble d'accords
alors est ce que tu aurais une main qui
te ferait plaisir quoi je dis vraiment
ce que je veux avec tu dis ce que tu
veux un joli carré de fait un joli carré
de 7 alors est ce qu'on va faire pour
tout le monde on va sortir le carré de 7
pour que tout le monde le voit bien que
c'est un chiffre magique 7
c'est joli il est un carré de cette très
très bon d'accord bien donc on va le on
entre on le met sur le jeu si je le mets
sur le jce tribu il n'y a pas d'intérêt
on va faire ça qu'on va couper un peu et
je vais même mélange est ce normal
donc je mélange un petit peu d'accord
voilà toc up
donc tu vois là quand même voeu de m je
veux dire c'est de moi j'ai pas tricher
devrais je dire le carré de 7 n'est pas
de subir les corps toc c'est bon parfait
je vais je vais commencer par
pas redistribué d'accord et ont fait un
poker fermé donc s'essayer à cinq
cartouches a qu'un dépêche
voilà d'accord toc donc voyons voir pour
l'instant tu n'as pas ton carré de 7
mais regarde on retrouve un set le set
de 13 et bien ce qu'on va faire c'est
klur yard tac on récupère les mains
comme ça aussi d'accord je remets
l'engin petit coup voilà
tu distribues cinq mains de poker bien
sûr une main côté moi je recoupe je vous
fais pas confiance je commence par le
deuxième joueur là oui je commence par
le joueur avait toujours vous avez
toujours pour moi je suis en face de toi
et nous nous si on appelle nos baleines
elles sont ici où nos pigeons elle
roulait à huy les baleines c'est ce
qu'on va permettre beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent alors moi je les regarde quand
on regarde les autres tu vois rien de tu
m'as distribuer c'est pas mal de wenger
je peux suivre ce qui va être le pire
voilà bon euh c'est pas ou feint ce
qu'ils ont fait avec gentil avec eux si
l'on veut qu'ils nous suivent
mais ils vont changer des cartes ab oui
oui on est enfermé 5 dont 2 5 à 3 voilà
tu vois on sait on sait pas voilà et toi
d'ailleurs un double faire parce que
c'est ça que faisait jaillir les ce que
j'ai fait j'ai stack et pour qu' il
puisse change avoir un peu de jeu et du
coup sauf là mais un petit peu mais du
moment que personne n'est au dessus d'un
carré je mets sur ton bâton carey
préféré avec mon caractère et ça m'a
réellement gareth bale s'est pas fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'heure on a parlé de bonneteau tu
vas me dire mais ouais mais le bluetooth
c'est pas avec quatre cartes avec trois
cartes
alors effectivement effectivement en
fait si tu veux quatre cartes mais il ya
en fait il ya trois blanche et ya juste
deux un joker leclerc voilà donc ce
qu'ils ont à faire c'est qu'on dépose tu
mets juste à 28 août ondoua tu vois la
toque d'accord et on va juste s'amuser
on laisse une carte blanche de couteau
ou avec le joker et les deux cartes
blanches
ok je vais mélanger les cartes d'accord
donc je montre ici on a une carte
blanche la passe de sous je la met
d'accord ensuite on a le joker je le
passe dessous juste le montre et ensuite
on a une carte blanche que je passe de
chou et je te la montre ok donc pour le
début je t'aide le joker est pas dessus
et pas de sous donc il est il est au
milieu perdu voilà parce que si on
contrôle on a bien une deux trois cartes
blanches qui va vérifier si cette
affaire voilà le dessus et dessous
voilà bah tiens de ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va on va t on va le déplacer
voilà et tu vas regarde je te redonne
une carte blanche je suis cool et
regarde le joker gai là on va juste le
récupérer comme se situe tentons le
plein comme ça voilà
et là on va faire ce qu'on appelle un
transfert de matière voilà ok donc tu te
souviens ici c'est blanc ici c'est blanc
on fait juste ça tu retournes et c'est
encore blanc parce que non le il est là
pour une mais bien sûr mais c'est est ce
que c'est moi j'ai fait un truc comme ça
dit quand tu cligner des yeux
j'ai fait ça c'est moi ok alors je tiens
on va on va réessayer peut-être une
dernière fois
d'accord on prend une carte blanche ok
je te la glisse
juste à la place du jockey jeu mais le
djoker ici ok d'accord donc dessus une
carte blanche la passe de sous ça va
d'accord ensuite alain à la base ça va
on a le jeu clermont le pass dessous
c'est facile et puis ensuite on a une
carte blanche et je la passe de sous
donc c'est très très simple où est le
joker au milieu alors ouais c'est vrai
mais tu aurais pu me dire aussi t'aurais
pu me dire dessus tu aurais pu me dire
deux sont aussi libres est valable ou un
milieu parce qu'en fait si tu veux
depuis le départ j'ai trois joker est en
fait une seule carte blanche si tu
vérifies c'est ça voilà c'est ça je
crois que ma théorie des cartes qui
s'imprime c'est la bonne voie la sesat 1
ça c'est super et du coup se tourne à
tulle explique quand on achète le jeu
mais quand on achète un oui d'accord ok
mortel merci beaucoup maurice était
c'est très très cool vous mais les liens
dans la description vers le jeu de
maurice vers la chaîne youtube de
maurice si vous voulez allez voir je
vous mettrai aussi les anciennes vidéos
qu'on avait faite sur la chaîne ensemble
comme ça si vous ne rencontrez maurice
que maintenant vous pourrez le voir et
d'ailleurs ici vous pouvez vous abonner
à la chaîne de maurice ici à mâcher mois
vous pouvez laïque et la vidéo moi je
m'appelle toujours fabien olicard tu
t'appelles toujours maurice de da est
ici vous avez deux autres vidéos qu'on
avait réalisé avec maurice sur cette
chaîne prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt